es ist nicht die stärkste spezialist
überlebt auch nicht die intelligentesten
sondern diejenige die am ehesten bereit
ist sich zu verändern
sie kennen den satz stammt von charles
darwin und die digitale transformation
führt uns grad täglich vor augen wie war
er ist wir müssen uns neu organisieren
doch wie geht das eigentlich und wer ist
wir
ein gespräch heute über neuland und
anpassung schön sind sie dabei und schön
sieht sich hier nicht alleine am tisch
sondern mit zwei personen die sich mit
dem thema gut auskennen ich freue mich
sehr
ist bei uns zu gast nicola zahn ist
politikwissenschaftler gründungsmitglied
der politischen kampagnen bewegung
operation libero und er arbeitet als
berater im bereich digitale
transformation und ebenfalls bei uns zu
gast ist thomas straubhaar professor für
internationale wirtschaftsbeziehungen an
der universität hamburg und ein
gefragter experte für den zusammenhang
von wirtschaftspolitik und
globalisierung ganz herzlich willkommen
ihr herz an sie schreiben einen blog
oder haben ihn geschrieben mit dem titel
brave new world service natürlich eine
anspielung auf alters huxleys brave new
world eine disco pi über eine totalitäre
gesellschaft aber wenn man sie ließ
kriegt man den eindruck ein pessimist im
sinn ich gerade ja in der tat würde ich
mich selbst auch nicht als pessimisten
bezeichnen sondern vielleicht eher als
kritischen optimisten die artikel serie
ist während eines aufenthalts in
singapur entstanden aus einem gefühl der
ernüchterung heraus wir haben so viele
hoffnungen mit neuen technologien
verbunden
aber irgendwie haben sich diese nicht
alle wie gewünscht erfüllt wie gegenteil
das pendel ist vom techno optimismus der
90er jahre in einen techno pessimismus
herüber geschwappt und das ziel des
blogs oder berater abzielt ist
eigentlich eine mittelposition zu
etablieren eine art techno realismus
denn ich bin weiterhin davon überzeugt
dass der technologische fortschritt
unterlaufen wird in einer besseren
gesellschaft zu leben wenn wir denn die
richtigen fragen stellen und die
richtigen diskussionen führen also die
richtigen fragen stellen möchten die
heute schon mal gegeben zumindest unser
bestes
der strauch von ihnen erscheint bald ein
buch mitte april ist es soweit das buch
trägt den titel die stunde der
optimisten
also sind sie ein optimist ja da bin ich
ein optimist sonst wäre ich ein
schlechter ökonom weil
wirtschaftswissenschaften sind ja
letztlich die wissenschaft die lehre der
knappheit die die erklärt wann und wie
wir engpässe überwinden können
und wenn ich mir die
menschheitsgeschichte den letzten paar
tausend jahre angucke dann ist das eine
einmalige erfolgsgeschichte und aus
meiner sicht gibt es keinen grund wieso
die heute gerade metall diesen neuen
technischen möglichkeiten zu ende sein
sollte
ich habe mir die form des buches schon
angucken kann und sie beziehen sich zum
beispiel auch auf steven pinker der war
kürzlich auch hier zu gast und macht
natürlich ein sehr fast schon rosarotes
bild unserer zukunft sagt der menschheit
geht so gut wie nie zuvor
jetzt haben sie vorhin gesagt dass
ökonom müssten sie ein optimist sein das
habe ich noch nicht verstanden nicht
dass es eine pflicht ist sondern ich
werde ein schlechterer ökonom wenn ich
angesichts von herausforderungen so zu
sagen pessimistisch würde sondern ganz
im gegenteil ist das eine inspiration
kreativ zu werden innovativ zu sein und
mit diesen neuen problemen ebenso
umzugehen dass die welt nicht mehr
schlechter der sondern eine besser wird
ich denke das ist auch unsere aufgabe
für kommende generationen eine welt zu
hinterlassen
die diesen kommenden enkelkindern
mindestens dieselben chancen dass mit
die wir selber auch hatten etwas finde
ich immer interessant wir haben jetzt
von problemen gesprochen neue probleme
nun ist ja der digitale wandel nichts
was eine naturkatastrophe wäre dass ich
gar nichts was wie ein meteorit auf die
erde fällt sondern etwas was wir machen
warum machen die denn etwas was so viele
probleme schafft das wird eine sehr
spannende unterscheidung gerade dieser
punkt dass es eben nicht eine
naturgewalt ist weil in der diskussion
sieht man ja oft dass man entweder sagt
man begibt so ein bisschen auf die
schiene der alternativlosigkeit der
rollt eine welle der digitalen
transformation auf uns zu und wir müssen
uns dem einfach aus liefer und schutzlos
wir können da nichts mehr beeinflussen
das müssen wir einfach akzeptieren und
auf der anderen seite haben wir dann
immer wieder das paradox dass gerade von
der
ethische seite gefordert forderungen
aufgestellt werden die einfach von
größenwahn zeugen wenn man das so sagen
möchte weil man überschätzt wie viel man
das wirklich beeinflussen kann
aber wie sie gesagt haben es ist nicht
eine naturgewalt sondern bereits dadurch
dass wir diesen technologischen wandel
haben wir können diesen mit gestalten
wir können ihr regeln aufstellen da sind
auch annahmen und ansichten bereits in
der technologieentwicklung mit drin
deshalb will ich auch nicht sagen dass
technologie personal ist und es bildet
auch immer die interessen ab der leute
die die dahinter steckt und ich denke es
auch wichtig im kontext rede auch andere
disziplinen darauf zu verweisen dass es
nicht nur probleme sind sondern eben
auch chancen und dass uns die
verhaltensökonomie oder die
verhaltenswissenschaftliche aufzeigt
dass menschen dazu tendieren die risiken
über zu schätzen und die chancen zu
unterschätzen und das ist ein typisch
menschliches phänomen und ich denke das
wird auch gerade im thema
digitalisierung und diese option und
allem was auf uns zukommen wird genau so
sein dass wir zuerst mal die probleme
sehen weil es unseren status quo das
bisherige infrage stellt das gewohnte
irgendwo nicht mehr gültigkeit hat und
dass man sich ändern muss und menschen
neigen dazu einfach gerne festzuhalten
was sie kennen nun stehen dann eben nur
die gefahren und verkennen komplett
welche risiken chancen damit verbunden
sind und da bin ich habe ihn ja vorhin
zitiert sagte sogar wie können nur
überleben wenn wir uns verändern oder
diejenigen werden die stärksten seien
die sich verändern können haben sie ein
stichwort gebracht was ganz wichtig ist
in diesem kontext nämlich die diese
option
und ich habe mir überlegt was mache ich
vor jeder sendung welche bücher könnten
wir den helfen zur vorbereitung und
welche requisiten könnte es geben die
ich mitbringen könnte und die sehen
einen leeren tisch und tatsächlich
glaube ich dass ich das beste requisit
es ist glaube ich die erste sendung die
ich moderiere oder etwas auf dem tisch
zu haben weil ich wirklich gemerkt habe
das ist wahrscheinlich die fraktion es
gibt nichts auf das ich mich so richtig
beziehen könnte stimmt dieses symbol
ja ich würde schon sagen weil der der
grundgedanke dieser option ist er
wirklich dass da gewesene radikal in
frage zu stellen und insofern ist das
bild der top hause als er passend
bei der diskussion um die diese option
allerdings aufpassen dass es nicht zu
einem selbst wert wird also dass man
nicht plötzlich sagen nur weil etwas
destruktiv ist ist das automatisch auch
gut sondern sozusagen über die frage
stellen ob das ist genau die
veränderungen die dahinter steht sie um
das korrekt gesagt
zuerst sieht man vielleicht die gefahren
und man merkt okay es könnte plötzlich
anders sein als ich mir das gewohnt bin
das heißt dann er zuerst mal etwas
zurückhaltung da aber das ist wirklich
auch eine chance sich zu fragen ob sind
denn die dinge wie wir sie heute machen
von der interaktion zwischen bürger und
staat zwischen den zu der interaktion
zwischen konsument und unternehmen muss
das so weitergehen wie wir das bisher
gemacht haben könnten wir das nicht auch
neu denken was genau heißt nämlich die
funktionen kann das definieren
ich denke vom wortstamm her das ist
etwas das eben so dass wir zu brüchen
kommen es wird nicht die fortschreibung
des bisherigen weiterhin gültigkeit
haben und das sieht man ja sehr schön
wenn man sich mal überlegt
es ist ziemlich genau zwölf jahre her
das ist das smartphone damals als iphone
gegeben hat und wie dieses medium
komplett die art und weise wie wir uns
unterhalten wie wir informationen
aufnehmen verändert hat ich meine das
iphone ist das letzte am abend was sie
sich angucken und das erste ermorden und
es bestimmt ihr komplettes leben und in
einer art und weise wie das vorher üben
und deshalb ist ihre beobachtung richtig
niemals der fall gewesen ist und in dem
sinne glaube ich ist das wesentliche der
diese option dass sie neuland betreten
und dass sie nicht dinge die in der
vergangenheit sicher als irgendwie gute
erkenntnis gutes geschäftsmodelle wiesen
haben in die zukunft tragen können dann
sicher sein kann dass sie wieder erfolg
haben sondern dass jede situation in
jedem bereich praktisch des täglichen
lebens bis hin wie sie kinder kriegen
davon bestimmt sein wird wie dieser
neuen technologien sich
entwickeln werden und nicht mehr die
alten dinge per sie die wahrheit ab wir
wollen wir heute über diese digitale
transformation sprechen ganz bewusst mit
menschen aus unterschiedlichen
disziplinen ökonomie
politikwissenschaften menschen aus
unterschiedlichen generationen wir sind
ja eigentlich fast drei generationen am
tisch und wir wollen unterschiedliche
themenfelder anschauen
beginnen wir doch mal mit der wirtschaft
und warum zuerst mal über die wirtschaft
sprechen
da gibt es einen ganz grundlegenden
wandel der bedeutet weg von der güter
ökonomie im zur daten ökonomie was ist
denn da dies rupp tief was ist so neu
ich denke das kann man sehr gut
veranschaulichen wenn man sich mal
überlegt wenn sie ihren auto kaufen und
das autofahren dann haben sie eine
gewisse abnutzung und irgendwann werden
sie das auto sondern müssen in der daten
noch nie ist das völlig anders es gibt
keine abnutzung es gibt auch nicht eine
konkurrenz um die daten an sich unsere
sendung heute werden vielleicht eine
million schweizerinnen und schweizer und
vielleicht noch 80 millionen deutsche
gleichzeitig angucken können und für die
einzelne person die uns zuschaut spielt
überhaupt keine rolle wenn dem ein 80
millionen deutsche oder 8 millionen
schweizerinnen und schweizer autos
fahren dann halb jetzt eng auf der
straße und ich glaube das ist der
unterschied dass daten sich nicht
abnutzen dass wir nicht im wettbewerb
der nutzung stehen dass es unfassbare
kosten gibt die daten zu verdichten zu
verarbeiten um anschluss kluge
information und wissen zu generieren
aber wenn sie das wissen mal haben dann
ist zu sagen wenn andere leute das auch
nutzen entstehen nicht nur kosten
sondern ganz im gegenteil wenn sie
wissen teilinformationen teile
gartenteil dann steigt für jede einzelne
person die diese daten nutzt der
mehrwert nächste mal bei allen risiken
die damit natürlich einhergehenden auf
dem gesicht noch eingehen ich würde auch
sagen dass das der zentrale punkt ist
dass das gut daten ein ganz andere
eigenschaften hat also das aus den
klassischen gewittern kennen und das
noch nicht wirklich wir verinnerlicht
haben oder wir komplett verstanden haben
was diese neuen eigenschaften von daten
bedeuten
man hörte beispiel dass immer wieder die
analogie daten sind das neue öl aber das
ist sehr irreführend weil das gerade bei
politik in der politik daran gewisse
erwartungen weckt beispielsweise was die
regulierung anbelangt wenn man dann
davon ausgehen kann ja dann können wir
ja einfach besteuern auf wer wie viele
daten hat dann können wir das
kontrollieren die wir das auch beim
traditionellen gütern machen aber das
funktioniert dann eben genau wegen
dieser anderen eigenschaften nicht mehr
ich möchte mir das ein dass man sagen
kann der handel mit daten zb oder reich
werden mit taten denken eine firma wie
facebook zum beispiel die daten nachher
auch weiter verwenden kann
das ist das ganz anderes wir nicht sagen
wir mal luftmatratzen herstelle und die
vertreibe aber was ich jetzt genau
darauf diese aktive für die ökonomie aus
wissenschaft sie sagen ja wir müssen
viel für die wirtschaft so zu sagen
sie sagen ja wir müssen die wirtschaft
die ökonomie neu denken es wird zum
beispiel keine volkswirtschaft mehr
geben
das ist dann ein zweiter effekt wird an
einem beispiel klar diesen aktiven
prozess klären wollen wenn sie sich mal
überlegen dass der größte hotelbetrieb
der welt kein einziges eigenes hotelbett
anbietet sondern eine plattform airbnb
im prinzip anbietet die völlig außerhalb
vom tourismus und gastgewerbe es
geschafft hat im prinzip auf der einen
seite kundendaten und auf der anderen
seite verfügbarkeit von betten
aufeinander abzustimmen und plötzlich
wird diese plattform von leuten die
nichts mit hotellerie überhaupt am hut
hatten
wird der größte hotelbetrieb der welt
der größte taxibetrieb der welt jubel
hat kein einziges taxi in seinem besitz
eines sohn einst größte buchhändler der
welt hatte lange zeit keine einzige
buchhandlung und das sehen sie dass die
produktive da gab es vor der märkte da
gab's netzwerke da gab es bestehende
kunden und nutzer nutzerinnen
und an angebots beziehungen und
plötzlich kommt da so eine konkurrenz
die idee im prinzip nichts anderes macht
daraus daten zusammen sie zu verdichten
passgenau zu machen und andere die diese
daten nutzen können damit zu verlieren
und wird schlagartig der größte betrieb
in diesem sektor der welt ich bin
natürlich gewohnt normativ zu denken als
als philosophin ich will immer wissen
ist das eigentlich jetzt gut oder
schlecht für uns sie beobachten erich
vock trotzdem ist es gut oder schlecht
ist es eine gute sache
also wenn sie dass sie zu beschreiben
taxi hotels die kannten uns ja ich weiß
nicht konami die ganze mehr bereiche
also ich würde das im einzelfall
anschauen und auch sogar für den
einzelfall noch differenzieren dass es
für gewisse akteure vorteilhaft sein
kann und für andere vielleicht eher ein
nachteil weil einerseits ergibt sich
daraus natürlich eine freiheit auch auf
individueller stufen das sind dann auch
die argumente die von ökonomie firmen
vorgetragen werden wir ermöglichen die
flexible arbeitsverhältnisse wir geben
leuten eine chance sich einen
zusatzverdienst zu erarbeiten durch
unsere plattform mit sehr niedrigen
einstiegshürden die kehrseite davon ist
er natürlich auch dass das quer in der
landschaft steht zu den bisherigen
regulierungen weil welchen status hat
ein solcher arbeitnehmer wie ist er
durch die sozialwerke abgedeckt war das
sondern alles fragen die wir jetzt
politisch diskutieren müssten weil das
fragen sind die durch dieses neue
geschäftsmodell auf geworden werden also
das heißt die politik muss sozusagen
neue regeln entwerfen weil die ökonomie
sich verändert genau absolut ich denke
das ist doch ganz offensichtlich dann
zum beispiel irgendwas der geschichte
sagen kann das war immer schon so man
muss da etwas neues sie aus also das ist
eine gute frage also auch die andere
fragen sind gut aber das eine gute frage
wer darüber streiten streiten wir uns
natürlich
moment das es gibt kolleginnen und
kollegen in allen disziplinen die sagen
was regt ihr euch darauf technologischen
fortschritt gibt es seit adam und eva
hat es immer gegeben
und irgendwo kam früher die ersten
dampfschiffe dann kamen die elektrizität
dann kam motoren getriebene autos das
hat es immer gegeben ja richtig aber ich
denke wenn sie sich mal wieder die
menschheitsgeschichte angucken dann um
mal keynes zu zitieren einer der ganz
großen ökonomen der vor 100 jahren 1930
er jahre geschrieben hat eigentlich ist
der fortschritt eine schnecke gewesen
über tausende von jahren hatte
fortschrittlich will ich jetzt geschafft
das leben den menschen wirklich zu
verbessern
es gab vielleicht über 4 5000 jahren der
verdoppelung des lebensstandard als und
jetzt in den letzten 100 jahren ist das
ja in jedem land der welt aus vielleicht
nordkorea das sich abgeschottet hat von
diesen entwicklungen ist den wohlstand
der menschen pro kopf in allen
dimensionen gestiegen wir leben länger
wir leben gesünder
wir können uns freie bewegen als jemals
zuvor und das denke ich ist anders als
es in früheren zeiten war und jetzt eben
dieses destruktive geht einfach breiter
schnelle und umfassende wenn ich mir mal
überlege künstliche intelligenz wird
eine möglichkeit haben das praktisch
alles was sie tun
irgendwo erfasst verwertet und dann
wieder genutzt werden kann
das ist glaube ich das neue dabei es ist
aber nicht so dass alle regionen der
welt gleichermaßen diese diese option
erleben und gleichermaßen auch
profitieren von diesem wandel würde ich
zustimmen aber würde ich dann die
gegenfrage stelle war das jemals anders
weil damit ist dann doch wieder den
bezug auf die geschichte nehmen wenig
des technologischen wandels der zwar
teilweise parallel geschieht dass die
gleiche idee oder die gleiche innovation
an verschiedensten orten unabhängig
voneinander entsteht aber dass das
trotzdem auch nicht gleichmäßig über die
welt verteilt ist schon nur wegen
unterschiedlichen rahmenbedingungen was
gesetzliche rahmenbedingungen anbelangen
beispiel patentrecht aber auch natürlich
was die anderen raumbedingungen
anbelangt bildung
zugang zur finanzierung für start-ups
und das ist natürlich ein klassisches
auch argument wird dass man sendungen
lang streiten könnte ob das jetzt
sozusagen gerechtfertigt es dass es
daraus wieder neue ungleichheiten geben
wird und die sind vorgezeichnet aus ganz
vielen gründen weil nicht alle
gleichermaßen zugang zu diesen
technologien haben weil vielleicht auch
im wandel die ein oder andere person
nicht wird mithalten können wenn dem
andere davon ganz besonders werden
profitieren können
das ist auch nicht neu ich denke auch da
vielleicht hilft ein blick auf die ganz
langen zeitreihen die doch zeigen dass
am ende über viele viele jahrzehnte eben
dann halt doch auch alle davon
profitieren auch in afrika geht es heute
den menschen besser als ihren eltern und
großeltern und urgroßeltern immer noch
viel viel schlechter als uns das ist
unstrittig aber vergleichsweise findet
auch dort dann sollte das gerne ein
fortschritt statt und da würde ich ihnen
völlig recht geben die frage ob mit
alternativen dass wenn wir das nicht
wenn wir keine digitalisierung hier zu
lassen würde ist afrika besser gehen wir
das würde ich damit ein riesen
fragezeichen dass ich auf rica wendt
haben vielleicht noch kurz alt es ist
finde ich ein sehr schönes beispiel für
das konzept des libro ging das durch den
technologischen auch nach ermöglicht
hilft lieb flogging als dass man so
quasi wie ein frosch einen sprung machen
kann und quasi mehrere evolutionsstufen
überspringen kann
weil es ist ja nicht ein linearer
prozess ist nicht so dass jede
technische innovation die beispielsweise
in westeuropa durch gemacht wurde dann
in anderen ländern auch so nach gemacht
werden muss und man kann gewisse
überspringen
und das sieht man in afrika sehr schön
mit dem konzept des mobile payment
beispielsweise von mir nicht zuerst
gesagt hat die abi bauen jetzt ein
landesweites filiale jetzt von banken
auf sondern wir haben einfach funkmasten
für das mobiltelefonnetz aufgestellt und
dann auch noch durch sonnenergie
gespiesen welcher weise idealerweise
genau und das hat dann den leuten
ermöglicht sofort zugriff auf diese neue
technologie zu halten und einen viel
schnelleren schwung das ist jetzt
interessant ich wüsste jetzt requisiten
eine schnecke um zu zeigen wie langsam
erwacht
lange zeit vor sich ging und ein frosch
der aufzeigt wie wir gewisse
technologieschritte einfach überspringen
können dem man ihm zu sagen meine
nächsten vorträgen berichten noch mehr
tiere dadurch so gemacht werden kann
ich würde gerne noch einmal zurück zu
dieser frage wie müssen wir die ökonomie
neu denken und noch einmal diese frage
stellen auch der nationalökonomie weil
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
sagen sie zum beispiel auch das bibb das
bruttoinlandprodukt oder überhaupt das
ist auch ein gebieten dem die sich gut
auskennen messinstrumente wie messen wir
wachstum in zukunft die können wir
vergessen ja geht nicht mehr
mindestens sind sie nicht mehr in dieser
art und weise zutreffend wie das in der
vergangenheit der fall gewesen ist sie
haben richtig wenn sich in bären vor 40
jahren studiert habe habe ich nationale
ökonomie studiert und die frage ist wie
wollen sie in der digitalen welt von
internet und virtuellen cloud abgrenzen
wo jetzt im internet umsätze und gewinne
letztlich geschaffen werden dann in
deutschland bin ich professor für
volkswirtschaftslehre geworden ich meine
volkswirtschaftslehre da hat das volk im
wort was ist heute in dieser digitalen
welt noch die gesellschaft die sozusagen
sich als gemeinsames homogenes volk
versteht wenn wir feststellen dass
gerade durch diese disruptiven prozess
eben auch die menschen zunehmend
voneinander unterschiedliche werden dass
diese typische schweizerin oder schweiz
oder der typische deutsche gar nicht
mehr definiert werden kann weil es durch
wir leben länger die lebensspanne ist
breite wir verändern uns beruflich mann
und frau bleiben nicht mehr unbedingt
ein ganzes leben zusammen es gibt
vielmehr verschiedene typen von menschen
in einer gesellschaft so dass auch das
volk nicht mehr gegeben ist und deshalb
bruttoinlandprodukt messungen da steht
steckt irgendwie das inland drin und
mein lieblingsbeispiel ist wenn ich
früher hat also
natur gemacht habe 1970 da habe ich ein
lexikon als belohnung von meinen eltern
gekriegt da gingen ihnen geschäft haben
umsatz erzielt und damit das zur mehrung
des bruttoinlandproduktes beigetragen
heute stehe ich nicht mal mehr auf und
gucken wikipedia nach und wikipedia ziel
keinen umsatz also würde das
bruttoinlandprodukt zurückgehen ob sie
nicht schneller besser zu informationen
komme und eigentlich dadurch einen
größeren nutzen haben und da gibt es
unendlich viele andere beispiele die
zeigen dass es wohl eine neuvermessung
der wirtschaft ich habe auf den zehnten
geburtstag auch noch einen brockhaus
geregelt war sehr stark darf sie lachen
nur sie haben vermutlich nie ein papier
lexikon glicherweise ich glaube ich
hab's noch nicht die gesamte produktion
aber eine soll man sagen also richtig 20
bänder nicht die 20 bände aber auch eine
zusammengefasste version in einem band
steht bei mir im bücherregal wird
allerdings muss ich zugeben selten
geöffnet
das läuft dann doch eher auch über
wikipedia aber der punkt mit den mit den
zahlen das definitiv richtig würde ich
sagen und die volkswirtschaftslehre ist
ja auch da waren von berlin des new york
sind davor standen den guten alten daran
neue indikatoren zu entwickeln aber es
ist auch für die politik und auch für
die wirtschaft sehr relevant weil gerade
wenn man sich auch das digitale werbe
business anschaut gibt es auch sehr
große diskussionen wie effizient ist das
wirklich was messen wir da stimmt das
denn wirklich und es gibt es aus der
managementlehre das schöne porno was man
nicht misst das kann man nicht managen
und das sollte sich auch die politik in
erinnerung rufen wenn es dann um solche
strategien geht wie sie jetzt überall
auf der welt aufpoppen über künstliche
intelligenz über andere technologien was
man da alles erreichen möchte dass man
dann auch nicht vergisst sich die frage
zu stellen okay wie können wir das denn
wirklich messen aber wachsen wir dennoch
also wenn wir es nicht messen können die
wissen wir denn noch kurz nach wachstum
gibt wissen wir das gar nicht nur so
behauptung wachstum in allen voran und
sowie die einen sachen wachstum ist mir
so nicht gut ja aber da glaube ich
unterliegen wir als menschen und in dem
sinne auch als wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler einem trugschluss dass
wir glauben dass wirtschaftliches
wachstum irgendetwas zu tun hätte
mit organisch biologischen
naturwissenschaftlichem wachstum also
die wirtschaft wenn die wirtschaft
wächst dann wachsen paar zahlen
letztlich und die frage ist ob wir
dadurch irgendwie die menschen glücklich
machen können und ob wir dadurch mehr
wissen generieren und damit irgendwie
dass das leben der menschen verbessern
und da glaube ich da hab ich mich den
geringsten zweifel dass auch unsere
kindeskinder in dem sinne wachsen werden
dass sie mit den dingen die ihnen dann
eben mal in 20 50 100 jahren zur
verfügung stehen auch wieder ganz grün
geringe herstellen werden und dadurch
das hat mit biologie eigentlich nichts
zu tun weil gerade alles was sag ich mal
im digitalen bereich zu wachstum führt
primär ressourcen schont der dass der
programms hat nicht mehr 20 bände wo sie
papier brown und den müssen sie ins
geschäft schleppen und sie mit dem auto
holen ihn und stellen ins bücherregal
und da ist wird überall dinglich was
produziert das machen sie heute
papierlos und in dem sinne ohne dass die
physische güte brauchen und irgendwie
schaffen mehrwert und mehr nutzen und
das wird auch in 50 oder 100 jahren der
fall sein ich will natürlich jetzt keine
wachstums diskussion führen aber sie
liegt jetzt so oft er habe ich meine sie
sind wirklich eine generation und dran
oder sogar zwei blicken sie auch so
positiv darauf gibt ja auch viele
menschen die sagen wir müssen wirklich
schluss machen mit dieser idee dass
grenzenloses wachstum möglich ist gerade
mit blick auf die ressourcen ja ich sehe
das aber gerade wegen dieses schiff sind
so immer mehr dienstleistung und immer
weniger industriegüter und schauen auch
eher positiv was ich habe nicht das
gefühl dass das dass das wachstum
verschwinden wird oder sogar das
verschwinden sollte und in bezug auf die
ressourcen sehe ich das sehr ähnlich das
wenn es einfach diese verschiebung hin
gibt zu vermehrt digitalen leistungen
die zwar natürlich auch gewisse
ressourcen in anspruch und in siders nun
edelmetalle wenn es um geräte geht oder
elektrizität wenn es um die
dienstleistungen geht
aber dass das eine das sagen in ganz
andere art von ressourcenverbrauch ist
wie das von den klassischen
industriegütern gehen also ich werde mir
nicht fünf kühlschränke kaufen wollen
ich teile mir vielleicht sogar einen
kühlschrank mit einer intelligenten
einfach mit den anderen leuten die auch
in einer wohnung sind insofern muss ich
das nicht ausschließen wachstum und
ressourcenschonung vielleicht nur um
diese frage doch noch mal zu klären
meine frage na ja auch wie messen die
ihr wachstum
diese indikatoren nicht mehr gibt das
habe ich noch nicht verstanden so wir
zahlen ja angedeutet hat das ist
letztlich neue indikatoren auch bedarf
die jeden letztlich festhalten was ist
eigentlich das ziel einer gesellschaft
und das kann bei glück zufriedenheit
beginnen kann andere charaktere mit
einschließen die letztlich bestimmen ob
sich eine gesellschaft die in diesen
neuen umwelt besser fühlt als es in der
vergangenheit der fall gewesen ist und
in dem sie das bruttoinlandprodukt dann
nur eine unter vielen maßstäben und ich
würde sagen es ist ein falscher werden
den maßstab wird um das abzubilden was
in einer digitalen welt basieren wird
sie haben ja bei der oecd genau zu
dieser frage studien durchgeführt
ja es war ein bisschen eine andere team
aber es gibt dort teams die genauer
befassen mit der frage wie können wir
neue indikatoren entwickeln für diese
digitalisierte gesellschaft müssen wir
die konzepte die etwa bei und konzepte
wie wertschöpfung gewinn etc
wie können wir die neu denken oder so um
umformulieren oder neue indikatoren
entwickelt dass wir das wirklich messen
können weil die wirtschaftsservice
beschrieben wurde verändert und das
große werk in progress jetzt sind ja auf
jeden fall auch schon beim punkt
angelangt dass die wirtschaft
grenzenlose ist globalisiert ist die
politik aber schon ein stück weit sich
noch in grenzen bewegt oder es gibt
zumindest vielleicht sowie verschiedene
konzentrische kreise die in oder babbels
den einander eingreifen wie wissen wir
dieses verhältnis neu denken ich würde
gerne über diese frage ein bisschen mit
ihnen nachdenken es gibt eine zu hause
und 100 größten wirtschaftseinheiten
sind 69 konzerne und 31 sind starten
was macht das mit unserem verständnis
von politik und wirtschaft
also ich kann jetzt nur für die
wirtschaft sprechen für die politik kann
dann sicher anders besser machen ich
denke man muss einfach alle arten
konzepte auf den prüfstand stellen und
eben insbesondere konzepte die noch
immer
ökonomischen größen eine volkswirtschaft
denken die sind und werden zunehmend
obsolet werden weil sie falsche
ergebnisse produzieren und eben noch in
welten denken die dem industriezeitalter
oder vielleicht sogar demokrat
zeitalters noch weiter zur rückkehr
entsprechen meinen adam smith hat seine
theorie mich am beginn einer
industrialisierung auf der grundlage
auch der damals einsetzenden
industrialisierung gemacht und das denke
ich dass wird sich immer weniger
bestätigen und deshalb wenn sie gerade
nicht wie muss politik da reagieren
jetzt aus als ökonom gesagt erstens
nicht indem man alte konzepte versucht
in dem sinne zu retten dass man die neue
welt den alten konzepten so zu sagen
dass man die so ab reguliert dass sie
den alten konzepten entspricht sondern
dass man bereit ist eine neue politik
sind neue herausforderungen zu finden
und dass man nicht in dem sinne
extrapoliert was in der vergangenheit
gut war dass das auch in der zukunft
richtig sein werden ich würde auch sagen
diese entwicklung dass private akteure
auf einer globalen ebene mindestens zu
relevant werden wie starten ist auch
nicht nur eine entwicklung
digitalisierung sonders hatten wir auch
schon bei der globalisierung vielleicht
sogar schon schon früher und da die
politik auch entsprechend darauf
reagiert indem man diese konzepte die
global governance eingeführt hat weil
man gesagt hat okay wir sehen uns ein
wir müssen uns hier mit probleme passen
die wir nicht mehr nur rein national
lösen können und das hat ja auch dann
zur etablierung von neuen institutionen
geführt die sind mal ein bisschen
formeller mal ein bisschen weniger
formeller bestimmte uno gremien g7 et
cetera diese ganzen meetings und man
muss sich auch wirklich in den
internationalen beziehungen damit
auseinandersetzen dass private akteure
sprich firmen teilweise sogar in
individuen relevante akteure geworden
sind auf einer stufe mit starten und das
führt auch bei den staaten bereits zu
einem umdenken so hat beispielsweise
dänemark einen eigenen botschafterposten
geschaffen der sich nur aus tauscht mit
technologiefirmen als nicht mit anderen
staatlichen einheit das macht er zur
teilweise auch aber teil seines mandats
ist vor allem der austausch auch mit
privaten aktuell
überlegen jetzt in einem rahmen eines
einst papers für voraus dass später in
diesem jahr publiziert werden sollte ob
das auch eine mögliche option für die
für die schweiz sein könnte dass man die
bestehenden institutionen dahingehend
anpasst dass sie diesen neuen akteure
auch einbinden können
sie haben jetzt voraus erwähnt dass man
kurz gut verstanden habe einen think
tank in der schweiz jährlich für
außenpolitische fragen interessiert
jetzt sind wir bei dänemark und das ist
ein gutes stichwort
es gibt die die dänische
wettbewerbskommissarin margrethe
vestager die geht im moment überhaupt
durch die presse so zu sagen weil sie
nämlich die monopolstellung der technik
ganzen anzukratzen versucht google apple
facebook die mussten schon mehrere
klagen jetzt erdulden
das gewicht dieser technik konnten ist
mittlerweile ebenso groß dass sie auch
sehr viel macht haben und west ag
erfährt seit 2015 einen harten kurs
gegen diese unternehmen ist freund to be
back
es ist in ordnung wenn man groß ist
darum geht es nicht
nein es geht darum die regeln
einzuhalten und darum kümmert sie sich
margrethe vestager die eu
wettbewerbskommissarin
das bekam google diese woche zu spüren
google bekommt die nächste milliarden
buße aufgepumpt es kurz nach mittag hat
die eu wettbewerbskommission die dritte
geldstrafe gegen den amerikanischen
internetkonzern verhängt und das
bekommen auch apple und irland zu spüren
egal ob sie ihr iphone in rom oder
berlin kaufen den vertrag gehen sie mit
apple sales international ein
und die sitzen in cork in irland das
eu-mitglied irland hatte apple und
weitere große firmen ins land gelockt
und ihnen großzügig steuern ein
das verzerre den wettbewerb befand die
kommission und forderte apple muss jetzt
die steuern nachzahlen
13 milliarden euro plus zinsen
apple hat inzwischen gezahlt und
berufung eingelegt genauso wie irland
das angst hat die großen firmen zu
verlieren
es gibt viel zu tun wir werden weiterhin
daran arbeiten dass die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit des gemeinsamen
marktes erhalten bleibt haben wir dazu
ist es die richtige strategie politik
auf ökonomie an verwenden
ja ich finde das ist natürlich ein
vorgehen das von seiten der us
amerikanischen politik sehr stark
verurteilt wird weil man sagt das ist
einfach bashing unserer konzerne
europäische union ist sauer dass sie
selber nicht solche konzerne
hervorgebracht hat wie wir das tun und
wir werden jetzt grassiert für bestraft
für unsere leistungen aber ich finde das
vorgehen schon richtig denn es geht hier
so steigt wie schlussendlich um
kartellrechts und wettbewerbsrecht und
ich finde dass das auch eine möglichkeit
ist die rechte des individuums
durchzusetzen weil klar profitiere ich
von den leistungen von apple google etc
aber wenn das ein monopol wird kennt
können wir dann gerne diskutieren es
gibt ja leute aus der tech-branche sagen
monopole sind super weil dann kriegen
die leute eine gute ein gutes
standardisiertes produkt aber die
brauchen perspektive das natürlich nicht
der fall sein sondern das sollte man
wettbewerb haben und wenn
wettbewerbsverzerrung stattfindet ist es
richtig dass diese auch bestraft wird
kann niemand ein beispiel haben also
nehmen wir mal an facebook hatten
monopol dann wäre die pro seite
wir kriegen ein gutes facebook produkt
und die contra seite die die was genau
sagen ja ich kann nicht zu einem anderen
anbieter gehen also ich bin als felsen
uns doch nicht auf facebook sagen ja das
stimmt eben bei mono poser nicht mehr
ich bin ein komplett ihnen ausgeliefert
sie können features hinzufügen ändern
sie können mit meinen sie können die
datenschutzerklärung plötzlich anpassen
dass sie viel weitergehend ist als das
zuvor der fall war
sie können sich neue ideen ausdenken wie
sie mit meinen daten umgehen können und
ich als benutzer hat er nur die wahl auf
facebook zu bleiben oder nicht und wenn
es einmal
liszt hat man so starke netzwerkeffekte
dass die sozialen kosten für mich als
individuum diese plattform zu verlassen
so hoch sind dass ich bereit bin sehr
viele nachteile in kauf zu nehmen um
diese vorteile weil sie nutzen zu können
und bleibe dann auf der plattform er
schaut sie haben in einem interview
kürzlich mit der tat gesagt man soll
firmen weder regulieren noch steuern
genau und ich denke das ist auch in
diesem ein spieler wirklich gut
herausgekommen dass nämlich die
kommissarin zwei dinge vermengt hat die
nicht vermengt werden müssen
das eine ist unstrittig dass man jedes
monopol und abhängig in welchem sektor
tätig ist
mit wettbewerbs gesetzgebung daran
hindern soll marktmacht zu lasten von
kundinnen und kunden zu missbrauchen das
ist unstrittig
ich glaube das ist gängige lehre die
sagt das geht immer zu lasten von
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher deshalb
muss den missbrauch bekämpft werden aber
das heißt nicht dass wir monopole per se
bekämpfen müssen weil monopole dieser
janusköpfigkeit die sich schon
angesprochen haben besitzen
auf der einen seite das sonnen gesicht
das sagt dadurch kriegen wir eine
unglaubliche gute versorgung von neuem
wissen zum beispiel in der medizin all
die daten die dann gesammelt werden
helfen mir dass der arzt bei mir zuhause
klingelt bevor ich krank werde und sagt
morgen haben sie ein problem nehmen sie
heute diese handlung vor auf der einen
seite hat dann vielleicht der monopolist
diese daten und vermarktet die wie das
facebook gemacht hat mit anderen dingen
dass ich beispielsweise plötzlich nicht
mehr versicherbar bin weil die sagen der
hat mal ein herzinfarkt gehabt und die
sind hohes risiko dass ich mir nicht so
also ich hab den unterschied noch nicht
verstanden herr straubhaar sie haben
gesagt da werden zwei dinge ist ein
mensch das war das zweite was sie dann
gesagt hat dann ist plötzlich auf die
gewinne ein
gewinne heißt noch nicht unbedingt dass
da in dem seine marktmacht missbraucht
wird sondern das kann sein dass die
einen informationsvorteil haben dass die
dinge besser machen als ihre
konkurrenten es ja noch um steuerfragen
genau und deshalb ist die besteuerung
etwas ganz anderes und ich glaube das
ist das habe ich in bar zu interview
gesagt macht das nicht über besteuerung
dass das dümmste was sie machen können
weil wenn ihr digitale dienstleistungen
besteuert da hab den ersten schon das
problem zu definieren wann beginnt die
digitale dienstleistungen dann müssen
sie diese fernsehsendung hier auch
irgendwie steuerlich sie plötzlich
relevant weil das gegen die
digitalisierung zu tun hat dann gibt es
gute digitalisierung schlechte
digitalisierung ganz schwierig zu
unterscheiden
zweiter punkt wird jammer nehmen dass
wir in europa in der schweiz
zurückfliegen gegenüber diesen
amerikanischen konkurrenz- und dann
besteuern wir ausgerechnet die dinge die
uns vielleicht helfen in diesen
segmenten aufzuholen deshalb sage ich
macht das nicht über steuern machte es
über den ersten teil ist ein spiel ist
nämlich den missbrauch den ihr hart
bestraft und in dem sinne finde ich
dieses urteil sehr viel darf ich noch
ganz kurz fragen was genau ist der
missbrauch war sie haben gesagt monopole
haben auch einen vorteil
also wann beginnt denn die
monopolstellung missbräuchlich zu sein
wählen sie als kundin oder kunde zu
etwas gezwungen werden was sie nicht tun
sollen
sehen sie das ähnlich mit den steuern ja
und wir können jetzt vielleicht hier
auch noch kurz ergänzen dass die
diskussion um die einführung einer
digitalen steuer auf europäischer stufe
dem sie eine gescheiterte ist dass man
gesagt hat okay zuerst sind 13 länder
vorgeprescht frankreich hat das
angekündigte deutschland was eher
zurückhaltend andere länder haben sich
auch angefangen zu überlegen und haben
gemerkt okay wir wollen keinen
europäischen flickenteppich wenn dann
wollen wir eine europäische lösung das
ist aber jetzt nicht zustande gekommen
jetzt hat man gesagt wir wollen dann
eine globale lösung sprich das ist auf
ewig aufgeschoben
aber ich finde dass ich sehe das
eigentlich ähnlich man sollte das
wettbewerbsrechts durchsetzen zum
missbrauch von monopolen das ist auch in
dem sie die nicht neu war das hat
microsoft in den 90er jahren schon als
sie uns gezwungen haben immer den
internet explorer mit dabei zu haben und
die wir mal microsoft hat das dann auch
gut überlebt
machen wir einen schritt weiter es gibt
eine große diskussion im moment das
eigentlich stellung von europa ist weil
viele sagen würde es gibt diesen blog
stellung der block konfrontation im
moment zwischen den usa die sehr wenig
staatlich regulieren wollen
und china russland die viel staatlich
regulieren wollen
china denkt mit dem ganzen system des
social crm systems der gläserne bürger
der wirklich ganz real entsteht oder
russland das im februar verkündet hat
sie wollen ein eigenes internet
aufschauten unabhängig von den usa also
man sieht wie zwar ganz unterschiedliche
denkweisen wie viel staatliche
regulierung wie sehr soll der staat
eingreifen und eine idee ist europa
könnte so eine mittelposition sein
was genau soll europa dar und und was
trauen sie europa auch zu europa im
moment andere probleme stichwort braig
sie zum beispiel ich sehe auch nicht
unbedingt jetzt den bedarf eines neuen
europäischen weges weil dieser alte weg
in dem zusammenhang würde ich sagen
den kann man ruhig noch etwas weiter
gehen nämlich eben ganz klar zu sagen
und das ist anders als in amerika wo
unter umständen von einem tag auf den
andern so großer monopole auch
zerschlagen werden können ich meine das
hat standard oil ist erschlagen worden
tnt also die amerikanische telefon und
telegrafen company ist zerschlagen
worden über nacht einfach gesagt ihr
habt eure macht ausgereizt zu lasten der
volkswirtschaftlichen vor und nachteile
und ihr werdet zerschlagen wird in
europa eigentlich gesagt wir lassen
monopole zu und gucken mehr auf die
effekte weil eben monopole das darf man
nicht vergessen dass lernen wir unsere
studierenden in den ersten semestern
auch ihr gutes haben weil in aller regel
monopole von innovations- vorsprüngen
leben bzw umgekehrt den
innovationsvorsprung den ich als
journalist habe ist eigentlich für viele
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer der
antrieb nach neuen denkens zu suchen und
deshalb ich würde nicht sagen dass wir
jetzt einen neuen dritten weg bräuchten
der irgendwie inbetween ist was wir tun
müssen ist das haben sie angesprochen
das macht mich viel mehr sorgen dass das
auch in europa gang und gäbe wir diese
scoring oder dieses gläserne kunde und
das geschieht bei uns vielleicht nicht
so wie in china durch autoritäre
zentralregierung von oben
sondern das geschieht bei uns über
versicherungen die sagen wenn du diesen
oder diesen kolonie wartet täglich
schützen
sehen sie es ähnlich sie finden auch
europa schön gut da wir müssen
eigentlich nicht noch mehr an einer
europäischen drehten idee arbeiten nein
ich sehe diese notwendigkeit für einen
dritten weg schon ein bisschen mehr weil
ich das gefühl habe dass die europäische
die amerikanische die diskussionen auch
die russische chinesische diskussion
beides in welten führen in denen ich
nicht leben möchte weil entweder der
staat zu viel kontrolle hat oder
unternehmen zu viel kontrollen haben und
ich denke gerade der punkt was sich auch
angesprochen habe mit der zerschlagung
über nacht dass das eine stärke es kann
eine stärke von europa sein dass wir
eben einen rechtsstaat haben dass wir
klare regeln setzen und diese auch in
forsten und sicherstellen dass das man
sich daran hält wie dass man mit solchen
urteilen der fall sein kann und dass wir
es auch schaffen die frage zu beamten
beantworten wofür wir die technologie
einsetzen würden
denn für autoritäre system ist klar dass
sich die technologie zum machterhalt
einsetzen wollen für das amerikanische
system ist klar dass es um
profitmaximierung geht um sonst nichts
und ich denke hier stellten hier bilde
sich eine lücke eröffnen für europa zu
sagen okay wie können wir technologien
für das wohl der gesellschaft nutzen
in welcher welt möchten sie dein leben
definitiv in dieser letzten jahr so um
wie sieht die konkrete ausmachen sie
mein beispiel wenn das einfach geht er
kommt einfach wie viel zeit ich noch
habe aber beispielsweise wird die
technologie vielleicht können wir es
umdrehen und sagen aber sein grundsatz
sein sollte meiner meinung nach wäre das
technologie mich als individuum nicht
einschränkt sondern mir mehr
möglichkeiten gibt also beispielsweise
habe ich durch eine sinnvolle
aufgesetzte verwaltung sehr gute
interaktion mit dem start wenn ich
irgend welche staatlichen
dienstleistungen beantworten möchte dann
geht das sehr problemlos sehr einfach
ich kann auch daten über mich selbst
erheben und beispielsweise bei benefiz
daraus ziehen und beim beispiel der
versicherungen zu bleiben gesundheit
ich kann wenn ich sport mache habe
bereits heute messen wie gut das wir
haben das kann interessant sein für mich
aber gleichzeitig setzten dann die
regeln die wir in einer solchen
gesellschaft haben und stellen sicher
dass diese information über mich nicht
gegen mich verwendet werden können was
genau oder diese negativen aspekte des
scorings
die sie angesprochen haben ich glaube
das ist so die schwierige balance die
wir halten müssen so dass wir nicht nur
den reinen effizienzdenken verfallen und
sagen ja wir sagen jetzt ganz viele
daten und machen dann wie das umfeld von
social physics der fall ist wie für
messen kann sich alles um steuern das
dann ganz genau sondern es gibt in
dieser gesellschaft in frage kommen
nehmen wir das beispiel mobilität am
morgen komme ich aus meiner wohnung
möchte zur arbeit fahren oder sonst
wohin
dann zeigt mir eine intelligente system
oder in die intelligent des ökosystems
sagt mir ja das wäre jetzt die beste
route die könntest du nehmen aber in
dieser gesellschaft habe ich dann immer
noch die möglichkeit wieder zu sagen
nein heute möchte jetzt lieber am fluss
entlang laufen auch wenn das vielleicht
weniger effizient ist und das ist dann
möglich ohne dass ich dafür bestraft
werde
es gibt dieses sprichwort der schlaf
relaunch für die ids oder ich frage mich
dann schon wie soll das funktionieren
also ist es wirklich möglich dass wir
die vorteile der digitalisierung wollen
und die ganzen nachteile nicht mit
einkaufen müssen
das muss doch ziel der politik sein das
muss genau ziel der diskussion in einer
gesellschaft sein
nach regeln und institutionen und
verfahren vor allem zu suchen
die eben genau das was sie ansprechen ob
die aber die großen treiber der
digitalisierung sind auch unternehmen
und die wollen ja gewinn machen die
wollen ja was davon haben also haben die
doch kein interesse daran ihnen gratis
dienstleistung uns das ist ja nicht neu
das ist ja glaube ich das ist das
klassische system eine marktwirtschaft
in dem wir hoffentlich auch in zukunft
leben weil sie sich in der vergangenheit
als so erfolgreich erwiesen hat und
hoffentlich nicht durch diese prozesse
plötzlich auch da neue fragestellungen
zu erleben sind
aber ich habe das unternehmen gewinne
machen ist nun einmal der motor
unternehmerischen handelns und dafür zu
suchen und bessere lösungen und
innovativ zu sein und davon leben wir
und haben gut gelebt auch als
gesellschaft gut gelebt und dann ist
eben die frage wie gehen wir mit
besteuerung zb von gewinnen aber nicht
von digitalen technologie
und daher da helfe ich mit zu
diskutieren das finde ich spannend wie
wollen wir in zukunft öffentliche güter
wie straßen bildung gesundheit in der
schweiz finanzieren wenn ein zunehmend
größerer teil des kuchens entsteht durch
daten und nicht mehr durch waren dann
müssen wir nämlich besteuerungsverfahren
auch anpassen und das sind neue fragen
die wir zu stellen habe habe ich würde
nicht sagen dass das jetzt etwas ist was
wir da nicht lösen können haben sie
vorhin skizziert in welcher welt sie
leben möchten eine große frage ist ja
auch wie die digitalisierung und die
demokratie ineinander greifen sie sind
gründungsmitglied von operationen libero
einer kampagnen bewegung die vor allem
auf soziale medien setzt oder mit
sozialen medien ihre großen erfolge
eingefahren ist gleichzeitig ist das ja
so etwas zweischneidiges wir sehen auch
dass beispielsweise der projekt- oder
die weiß und donald trump in einer art
und weise mit sozialen medien zum
beispiel umgegangen ist wo man denkt das
hat dann mit demokratisierung einer
bevölkerung nicht mehr so viel zu tun
ja absolut das ist kein kein
selbstläufer wir können nicht einfach
davon ausgehen dass neue technologien
automatisch zu demokratischeren system
einführen
das hat man am anfang gedacht das war ja
teilweise auch die vision wie sich die
grünen dafür gestimmt dass soziale
netzwerke angedacht haben mit mark
zuckerberg hat gesagt unsere vision ist
dass alle leute zu verknüpfen zu einer
großen community im twitter hauptpartie
hat man während des arabischen frühlings
partys gefeiert weil man gedacht hat ja
wir haben einen beitrag zur
demokratisierung geleistet ein
autoritäres regime weggefegt aber dass
überhöht die technologie weil die kann
auch genau für das gegenteil eingesetzt
werden für den machterhalt in einem
autoritären system für die unterdrückung
von menschenrechten und man auf das
beispiel von operation libero
zurückzukommen ist digitale technologie
einfach ein mittel um unsere nachrichten
herzustellen um sie zu verbreiten um die
zufrieden die freiwilligenarbeit zu
koordinieren
das hätte man auch jetzt bereits tun
können aber diese neuen technologien
ermöglicht es uns einfach dass es
einfacher und kosteneffizient möglich
ist wenn man alle diese verschiedenen
dinge anschaut was
sozusagen sich verändert dank der
sozialen medien in der politik dann
fällt auf dass es sehr viele dinge gab
in denen man gegen etwas sein konnte
also operation libero wurde stark im zu
fall bringen von initiativen zum
beispiel oder den trump hat in erster
linie mit den sozialen medien hillary
clinton diskreditiert denken sie es wird
die möglichkeit geben dank der
digitalisierung für etwas zu sein
absolut also ich denke auch dass das
nicht ein phänomen ist das nur mit den
technologien zu tun hat sondern dass das
meer der kampagnen logik entspricht man
kennt der politikwissenschaft auch die
status quo ristic sprich es ist
einfacher die leute davon zu überzeugen
dass alles mal erst so bleiben soll wie
es ist die veränderung das ist immer
schwieriger zu verkaufen aber überhaupt
nicht unmöglich und insofern sehe ich ja
auch nichts dass diese technologien nur
dafür eingesetzt werden können
etwas zu verhindern ist auch unser
anspruch proaktiv ideen einzubringen und
für etwas zu sein
ich denke dass das auch zeigt und das
hatten sie ja schon früher mal gefragt
das einfach eine gewisse affinität
zwischen wirtschaftlichen
technologischen entwicklungen und
politischen reaktionen sich auftut und
wenn sie sagen so volksparteien oder wie
in einer demokratie der volkswille
abgebildet wird das würde ich sagen war
früher vergleichsweise einfach weil
früher war die schweiz die
eidgenossenschaft sozusagen eine
vergleichs auch mit vier sprachen und
landesteilen dennoch ein vergleichsweise
homogenes gebilde man musste so ungefähr
was der alltag bedeutet für seine
nachbarn und und das ist heute glaube
ich so viel schwieriger geworden dass
eben dieser begriff der volkspartei und
des volkswillens viel schwieriger als in
der vergangenheit zu definieren sein
wird und dann ist eben die frage wie
bilden sich parteien oder bewegungen
denen ich viel zutraue auch positives in
zukunft um neue themen aufzugreifen da
würde ich eben sagen sind volksparteien
des klassischen zuschnitts bald einmal
am ende ihres lateins weil es diesen
typischen volksvertreter
das destruktive politik dass man politik
neu denken muss ihn zu bewegungen ein
anderer deskriptive bereich auf dem ich
noch zu sprechen kommen möchte ich
derjenige der arbeit und es gibt immer
wieder diese zahl von john maynard
keynes sie haben in einem bereits
erwähnt der hat gesagt 20.30 werden die
nur noch 15 stunden arbeiten
hat er recht gehabt wird das so sein
geht uns die arbeit wirklich so aus also
ich habe diesen esse ja auch gelesen da
geht ja um die ökonomischen
möglichkeiten würde unsere enkelkinder
wo der 19 30 geschrieben also das gesagt
hat in einer ähnlichen zeit in dem sinne
wie heute das viel unsicherheit
bestanden hatte viel pessimismus damals
nach dem ersten weltkrieg wird
weltwirtschaftskrise und der hatte den
mut und das finde ich wirklich fast
schon sehr ich zusagen jeden fall werden
technologische entwicklungen es den
menschen ermöglichen dass er nicht mehr
leben muss um zu arbeiten sondern dass
er eigentlich nur noch arbeitet um sein
leben gerade so finanzieren zu können
und dass es einen wandel gibt von dem
begriff und dem ethos den mit der arbeit
verbunden ist und wenn ich mir das heute
angucke und wenn ich die ganze harte
linie fahre dann sage ich erstens für
praktisch alles was standardisierte
tätigkeiten sind ist es eine frage der
zeit bis das roboter oder künstliche
genc schnelle pässe fehlerfreie und dem
sind auch irgendwann mal günstiger
machen werden und dass ich mir zweitens
die frage stelle
ist das nicht eine riesenchance ist
nicht eine riesenchance vielleicht über
arbeit neu nachzudenken und nicht mehr
arbeit als das wesentliche element des
lebens zu sehen sondern vielleicht das
was wir arbeiten und wie viel wichtiger
werden wird darüber wird ja jetzt seit
mehreren jahren vehement gestritten
einerseits wird was eintreten
andererseits auch ist das eine chance
oder ist das eine bedrohung
ich habe gedacht wir können ja mal ein
beispiel nehmen dass ich jetzt ganz
konkret vollzieht und zwar hat
deutschland ja entschieden auf
erneuerbare energien zu setzen dazu
gehört auch der ausstieg aus dem
kohleabbau 20 38 soll schluss sein und
ganz viele menschen 20.000 jobs sind
davon betroffen
schauen wir uns ganz kurz die situation
an es geht um viel über ein drittel des
deutschen stroms liefert die kohle
20.000 jobs ganze regionen hängen davon
ab
für sie soll gesorgt werden müsse
erreicht dass die menschen in den
regionen die chance bekommen eine eigene
struktur entwicklung voranzutreiben rund
40 milliarden euro sollen dafür
eingesetzt werden schlägt die
regierungskommission vor
auch die industrie soll entschädigt
werden und nicht zuletzt die
stromverbraucher sie sollen von den
steigenden strompreisen entlastet werden
denn kohlestrom ist billig aber eben
auch dreckig um die klimaziele zu
erreichen ist der ausstieg aus der kohle
unumgänglich natürlich ist es leicht
jetzt hier vom tisch in einem
fernsehstudio aus das zu kommentieren
und zu sagen so ist halt strukturwandel
hat sie mir gegeben wird es immer geben
da geht es um menschen und dennoch
glaube ich ist es aufgabe der politik
dafür zu sorgen dass diesen menschen
möglichst schnell neue alternativen in
sektoren und bereichen geboten werden
die eben auch zukunftsfähig sind und um
das zu schaffen das hat etwas mit
bildung zu tun mit fördermöglichkeiten
und uns so hat das auch klingen mag
je früher wir das tun umso besser und
das ist doch keinen sinn machen kann
heute noch junge menschen in den bergbau
zu schicken im wissen darum dass die
zeit immer schneller abläuft sondern
dass wir lieber ehrlich sind und auch in
der schweiz und in deutschland in vielen
anderen sektoren ehrlich sind und sagen
da kommen jobs ich aber eben das was ich
meine ist es ist natürlich ein schwacher
trost für diese menschen zu sagen das
ist doch schön wir werden nicht mehr so
viel arbeiten die können neu
überarbeiten nachdenken für diese
menschen ist es real und bezüglich
digitalisierung wird es mehr und mehr
eine realität für sehr viele menschen
es ist das grausame politik politik kann
nicht einzelfall schicksale verfolgen
sondern sie muss für das große ganze
vernünftige gängige brauchbare lösungen
anbieten lassen kann wenn es um
strukturwandel geht hat sie leider oft
die tendenz also mit sie ist die politik
gemeint profi tendenz diesen möglichst
heraus zu erzeugen also genau das zu
machen was die korrekte weise sagen
sollte man nicht tun weil es einfach
politisch opportun ist zu sagen wir
schützen euch jetzt noch ein bisschen
von diesen veränderungen die da kommen
und dann wird es einfach umso härter
wenn sie dann kommen das hat man auch in
der letzten legislaturperiode gesehen
gerade im digitalen bereich wo es darum
gegen bestimmte gesetzes gestimmt
bestimmte geschäftsmodelle zu schützen
als ein beispiel könnte man hier
beispiel dass das geldspielgesetz nennen
wo es darum ging das nationale anbieter
auch auf ein internet glücksspiel
anbieten könnten dass man diesen markt
aber schützt gegen ausländische anbieter
was natürlich dem zweck des des
geschäftsmodells plätze entgegenläuft
woldt denn die politik ihre innovation
her für die probleme der zukunft
da würde ich sagen das ist eben auch die
sucht früher hätte man als ich in meinen
jungen jahren als ökonom da hätte ich
ihnen jetzt einen masterplan vorgelegt
und irgendwie gesamtverkehrskonzept oder
gesamte ökonomie konzepte da gab in den
80er jahren gab es für alles ein
gesamtkonzept gesamtenergie
gesamtverkehr was immer so das würde ich
sagen 7 auf diese aktiv das ist vorbei
weil wir alle nicht so genau wissen wie
die welt in zehn 20 und 50 jahren aus
schaut sollten wir aufhören agenden und
sieben punkte pläne und großem maße
pläne auf den tisch zu legen und sagen
ich weiß jetzt wie das geht weil so wird
es nicht werden
und deshalb sollte politik eigentlich
nur noch so ein kompass aber nicht einen
wegweiser vorgeben sie sollte im prinzip
verfahren vorgeben das ziel aber nicht
den weg offen lassen sich einen
entspannten ansatz denn ich würde auch
sagen
heute kämpfen mit dem problem dass die
technologie an die technologische wandel
eine riesige geschwindigkeit hat die
politik muss dann immer so hinterher
hecheln und auf basis eines einzelnen
falles versuchen
ein gesetz zu erlassen das dann
teilweise auch unternehmensspezifische
industriespezifische ist aber die großen
fragen eben wohin so die gesellschaft
gehen das bleibt dann weg deshalb will
ich auch sagen dass man sich fokussieren
sollte auf einen rahmen auf wo man sagt
okay weise welche werte welche zentralen
rechte sind uns wichtig dass
institutionen braucht es auch dafür und
ein großes potenzial sehe ich im
austausch für sie verschiedenste akteure
man hat das im bereich der internet
regulierung sehr gut gesehen hat sich
nämlich der sogenannte multi stakeholder
ansatz durchgesetzt das heißt nicht nur
staaten diskutieren das nicht nur
diplomaten unter sich nicht nur die
firmen unter sich diskutieren sondern
die kommen alle an einen tisch alle
leute alle stakeholder die seinem thema
wissen beitragen können erfahrungen
beitragen können wünsche beitragen
können sind an sitzen am gleichen tisch
und können das ausland aber das ist ja
auch so das wesen von bewegung und
letztlich eben dass da eben plötzlich
ganz neue gruppen sich als stakeholder
auch irgendwo einbringen und uns sehr
wesentlich zu lösungen beitragen können
weil die dann auch politisch eher
akzeptiert werden eben jenseits
klassischer volkswirtschaftliche
nationale parteipolitische grenzen hier
vielleicht noch mal kurz einen schwenker
zu digitalisierung und technologie
die demokratie und digitalisierung zu
machen
es gibt auch ganz schöne beispiele in
dem so genannten sewig technology sector
wo es eben gerade darum geht
technologien zu nutzen und den
demokratischen prozess anzupassen wie
können wir beispielsweise leuten die
nicht stimmbürger sind in der schweiz
eine stimme geben auf einer plattform
dass sie mitbestimmen können oder auch
input geben können wie könnte man das
vernehmlassungsverfahren öffnen so dass
es einfacher ist auch für einzelpersonen
dort inputs zu liefern dass ich viel
potenzial für technologie
wir sind wieder zurück bei der diese
option ein neues die es nicht dazu
gekommen wir bleiben bei der schnecke um
den frosch ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich der ökonom peter drucker er
sagte einmal in zeiten des wandels ist
die größte gefahr mit der logik von
gestern
die probleme von heute lösen zu wollen
ich glaube das hat dieses gespräch auf
jeden fall gezeigt vielen herzlichen
dank dass sie hier waren härter
informationen gibt es auch mit blick auf
die familie kinder zu bekommen ist heute
zum beispiel nicht mehr schicksal
sondern eine frage der entscheidung
ich musste hart diskutiert nächste woche
mit china
warum es so schwierig ist diese
entscheidung überhaupt noch zu treffen
und jetzt gleich heften wir uns an die
fersen des weltenbummlers rudolf häusler
der sich in kuba und der revolution
beteiligte in spanien die kunst neu
erfand und seiner schweizer heimat doch
stets verbunden brief eine gute woche
für sie bis bald
[Musik]